e
année, la SAQ hausse ses prix.
- Ça augmente partout.
Les plaques automobiles
augmentent, tout augmente.
- C'est sûr qu'à un moment donné
ça devient lourd, les
augmentations tout le temps, là.
- C'est comme normal avec
les temps qui courent.
- 1458 produits subiront
une hausse de 2,4 %,
ce qui représente 69 cents
en moyenne. 539 produits seront
moins chers d'environ 1,3 %,
soit 28 cents. Et les prix de
1389 produits resteront stables.
Les coûts de transport et les
mes d'approvisionnement
en sont principalement la cause.
YVES LANGLAIS PLANTE, directeur
des comm. par intérim, SAQ
- Les cooduction
de nos fournisseurs qui
sont plus grands, donc pénurie
de main-d'oeuvre notamment,
approvisionnement aussi
de matière sèche, donc
les bouchons, les bouteilles,
tout est plus compliqué
à obtenir.
- La baisse des prix sur
certains produits s'explique par
la fluctuation de la monnaie.
- Il y a eu la dépréciation
de l'euro. Donc, l'euro
a baissé progressivement
dans les derniers mois.
Donc, ça se reflète dans
le prix, ce qui explique
la grande majorité des baisses.
- En 2022, acheter une bouteille
de vin ou de spiritueux coûte
en moyenne 3,6 % plus cher
qu'en 2021. Et 9 fois sur 10,
la hausse s'applique sur un des
articles les plus populaires.
SYLVAIN CHARLEBOIS, prof. distr.
et pol. agroalim., U. Dalhousie
- La SAQ performe relativement
bien depuis quelques années.
En fait, l'ensemble des
commissions de liqueur à travers
le pays fonctionne bien.
Les rendements sont excellents.
D'appliquer une hausse quelques
semaines avant les Fêtes, c'est
un peu opportuniste à mon avis.
- En 2021, les revenus versés
au gouvernement du Québec
étaient de 1,2 milliards
de dollars. En Ontario,
la LCBO a remis 2,4 milliards
pour la même période.
- Est-ce qu'on augmente
les prix simplement pour
augmenter les dividendes?
- La hausse vertigineuse
du coût de la vie force
les consommateurs à changer
leurs habitudes.
- Je regarde beaucoup plus
les prix qu'avant, vraiment, là.
J'essaie de trouver...
des rabais, des vins qui sont
quand même bons et moins chers.
- ... Et peut-être mettre
un peu d'eau dans son vin.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-Comeau
Radio-Canada, Mon